[MUSIC PLAYING]
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: Hello,
and welcome to I/O life.
I'm Florina Muntenescu,
and I'm here
with Chet Haase, the
Android Toolkit [INAUDIBLE]..
Hi, Chet.
CHET HAASE: Hello, Florina.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: Tell me,
Chet, what's new in Android B?
CHET HAASE: Are
there new things?
Let me think.
Uh, yes.
In fact, there are.
So there's a few new things.
One of the important ones that
we heard about in the keynote
too was about
dynamic app bundles.
But I think there's
another video on that.
So I'm going to leave people to
do their own research on that.
Something else that was
big was Slices and Actions.
So both of these are ways
of propagating intents
that your application
can take care of deeply
in other applications.
So you can propagate
this information in a way
that maybe the
Assistant or Search
can take advantage of that and
perform that action via, like,
a button.
Right?
So it can say, oh.
I can handle this.
You put it in an
actions.xml file.
And then Search or
some application--
Assistant or whatever-- can
propagate a button into the UI
so the user can click on
that to perform that debatch.
And slices is kind of like that.
It allows you to
perform these actions
but with a much richer UI.
Basically it's a way
for an application
to propagate rich UI to
perform all kinds of things
in another process.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU:
How about the battery?
Is there anything else,
finally, for battery?
CHET HAASE: How
about that battery?
Well, we are all power
users, unfortunately,
which means we need to
keep working on things
that we can do at
a platform level
to preserve battery for users
to get longer battery life.
A couple of the things
that are interesting that
are going on in this release
includes App Standby Buckets.
So we determine the
level of activity
that a user has
with an application.
And based on that
activity level,
we expose capabilities
of the platform
to that application or not.
It may not be appropriate
for an application
that the user hasn't
actually run for a while
to be taking up CPU
and battery doing
this thing in the background
that, probably, the user didn't
want them to be doing.
So that's one thing.
Another is Background
Restrictions.
So if we notice that
applications have bad behavior
characteristics, things
like holding wakelocks
for a very long period,
which means the system can't
go to sleep, or waking up
frequently or using services
when they're not on
power that they shouldn't
be as frequently
as they are, then
they'll be propagated
into a list
that the user can
see through Settings
and then disable background
capabilities for that app
to make sure that the user has
control with how much battery
is being used.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: Cool.
So we have our Slices, Battery.
Anything else exciting in P?
CHET HAASE: Well, there's
exciting and there's necessary.
One of the necessary
things that's there is that
we're preventing applications
from calling private API's.
It is possible now
to call API's, which
are not in the public platform.
But through reflection or JNI
you can get to these methods
anyway.
And we allow that
because we didn't
have a way to really stop that.
You can sort of query
this and go for it.
Well, now, in the
arc runtime, we
can detect that you are
calling these methods
from an application
when they shouldn't be.
And we can prevent that.
So in the preview release,
which we encourage everybody
to pick up and play with,
we have these methods
in a light gray or
dark gray list, which
means that you're going to get
either a warning in the log
or a toast popping
up on the screen.
So if your application is
calling these and shouldn't be,
you're going to get
a warning about it.
But when that release comes
out, it will be on a black list,
and we'll simply stop
it from being called.
So the call to action
would be, go run
with the preview release
for P, and make sure
that your application
is safe from these.
And if it's not, then
either fix your application.
Or if it is some facility
that you absolutely need,
then maybe it's something
that we can work on
and we can put it on
a white list instead,
but you need to tell us
that information which
is why we have the preview.
So give us that feedback.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: All right.
There is this Android--
CHET HAASE: No, no, no.
That's a totally
different object.
I think we need to
talk about text.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: Yeah.
What about text?
CHET HAASE: Text happened
in my larger toolkit tape,
so I understand that.
In fact, you understand that.
I want to ask you about text.
So what happened in text?
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: So in text,
we released a few new APIs.
Now, you can pre-measure text.
So this means you can move
all of that measuring work
that takes quite a lot of time
from rendering a character
to a background threat.
CHET HAASE: And why
is that helpful?
FLORINA MUNTENESCU:
Well, because then
the text is displayed
faster, so faster rendering
means less frames skipped.
CHET HAASE: Sure.
So it's also good
because, like, if it's
time for you to display
the text and then you
have to measure it,
it's not very helpful.
But a lot of times,
you know ahead of time
when you're going to need that.
So you can actually,
ahead of time,
shove it off to a
background thread.
So that by the time
you need it, then you
can display the text,
which is awesome.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU:
We added a new feature
for the user, the Magnifier, and
we also added an API for that.
So we now have three methods.
Magnifier, Show Updates,
and I think Dismiss.
And this means that, if you're
developing your own custom
views that also
display text, you
can also show that
Magnifier in your cost view.
CHET HAASE: Also, it's
not limited to text.
That's the cool thing.
We are using it for
text, because we
wanted to make it
easier for people
to manipulate the cursor.
But you can use it
for whatever you want.
If you need a zoomed in view,
that API is general purpose.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU:
That's right.
And I think we also
added some more
improvements on Smart Linkify.
Do you know more about that?
CHET HAASE: I do.
Smart Linkify is like
Linkify, except it's smarter.
So we already had the ability to
create links in a block of text
for you if we detect things like
phone numbers and addresses.
That's been there forever.
But now, through
machine learning
models that we have
on the system--
which are used for things
like smart text selection--
we can detect more
complex entities there.
Like you may select
a word which is
part of a larger phrase, which
we detect because of the entity
detection in the model.
You can ask Linkify to detect
those as entity links as well.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: Can
I now go back to this?
Because it feels like it's
looking over our shoulder.
CHET HAASE: Ah!
Yes.
OK.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: So
what's with the Android
with the jetpack?
CHET HAASE: So Android
Jetpack is a set of components
as well as
architectural guidance
for helping developers build
better Android applications.
Most-- I would say all
Android developers--
are familiar with a lot of
what is in Android Jetpack
already because we have taken
all the goodness of Support
Library and put it
under this banner.
And we are going to continue
to add to that, specifically
with the intent of making
Android development better
and easier.
So I'll give you some examples.
One of the big ones--
one of my favorite things
about Support Library
is App Compact and
the way that we
baked in the releases
for certain APIs
into the package names.
So now we have package
names like V4 and V9
with some of the APIs.
We don't even support
those releases anymore.
So I think all of the
existing developers
don't even think about it.
That's just noise at
the top of their file.
Right?
It's one of those imports
they never look at.
But I think if
you're new to Android
or if you're looking
at the documentation,
I think it's terribly confusing.
So we're doing a
major refactor where
we turn all those package names
into AndroidX dot whatever.
The other part of it is
the existing Architecture
Components are a
big piece of it.
Things like Lifecycle,
Support, and Room, View Model.
All of that stuff is good.
Also, the new Paging Library,
which went 1.0 this week--
Paging and Recycler View.
And we have two new things.
Actually there are two sides
here at the demo table.
We have Navigation Controller,
and we have Work Manager.
Navigation Controller
makes it easier
to create the links of the
flow of your application.
It makes things like
up versus back easier.
And we also have a
tool in Android Studio,
where you can visualize
this and create those links.
So it's sort of an
integration of the APIs
as well as the tool for making
this complex application
flow a lot easier to develop.
And then Work Manager is about
an easier way for creating
and executing background tasks.
So before, we would recommend--
well, JobScheduler is really
good for scheduling things
in particular times.
You know, when Wi-Fi is there or
when you're charging, whatever.
And that works really well if
you're on Kit-kat and above.
What if you're on
an earlier release?
Well we also have
JobDispatcher, which
is in the Play Services APIs.
Well what if you're
on a device that
doesn't have Play Services?
Well, then you're probably
rolling your own solution.
So applications would need
to do all three of these.
Work Manager is an attempt to
have a simpler, more elegant,
fluent API for
doing all this stuff
that handles all
of that for you.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: Right.
So lots of new things, both in
Android but also with Jetpack.
So check out all
the videos that we
have from Google
I/O. And also check
out the documentation on
Developer.Android.com.
Thank you, Chet.
CHET HAASE: Thank you, Florina.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: This
is Florina from I/O Live.
[MUSIC PLAYING]